la français figurent au palmarès de la
chanson aux états unis c'est en effet
michel polnareff qui depuis plusieurs
années vous le savez habite los angeles
qui voit son nom figurer dans ce qu'on
appelle là-bas le hit parade
michel polnareff on ne l'a pas beaucoup
vu depuis son départ mais grâce à robert
bouchard qui revient des états unis
voici un portrait de polnareff en plein
travail
du côté de la californie
c'est avec ce titre que michel polnareff
est arrivé au hit parade américain
bon nombre d'entre elles ne parlaient
d'eux
et pas que
la séquence
il ya un truc évidemment amusant c'est
que pour l'instant les américains
connaissent deux mois vainqueur des
écouteurs et c'est une c'est une image
que j'aime bien dans fakim qui me
ressemble pas complètement et et veut
dire je me promène pas dans la rue dix
ans déguisé en choeur avec des écouteurs
dans le disons que pour l'instant ma
voix comme ans est connue aux états unis
mais ma mon visage ne l'est pas encore
être au hit parade américain pas
française par m ouais c'est bien surtout
que c'est la première fois que ça se
passe aux etats unis
je dois dire que je suis assez assez
content vous j'aime bien lorsque
j'annonce certaines choses qu'elle se
réalise c'est tellement triste et des
choses qui se réalise pas
ce sont intéressants pour moi ici c'est
les les moyens techniques qui sont mis à
ma disposition les musiciens
exceptionnels qui a écrit à los angeles
j'aime beaucoup impression de voir de
voir grand que ce soit tant dans la
musique dans la chanson donc ce soit
dans la musique de film
aux etats unis michel polnareff se lance
donc dans une nouvelle carrière celle de
compositeur de musiques de fond un film
de dino de laurentiis avec mon metteur
en scène la mone johnson les interprètes
ans ans margaux et mériel hemingway les
deux petites filles de l'écrivain
ouais
ok ok
et
précédant cette dans cette musique de
film fils sa belle vie mystique et
j'essaie de traiter la musique de film
comme je prête mais disent que c'est à
dire avec beaucoup de soin et très
intéressant surtout que le personnage
professeur de musique électronique et
que ça donne l'occasion de montrer ce
que je sais faire avec cette douleur et
c'est la première fois que j'ai fait des
moyens aussi aussi importants mis à ma
disposition
finalement vous travailler aux états
unis pour payer aux impôts en france
non j'ai la peau jusqu'à je travaille
pas aux états unis pour payer des impôts
si jamais travailler pour payer des
impôts et je pense je ne souhaite à
personne d'avoir à travailler pour payer
des impôts ceci dit je dois de l'argent
aux aux impôts puisque site escroqués
par mon mon homme d'affaires était
supposé les payer et ça aussi je
l'éprouvé vu que il a été condamné par
défaut bus n'est pas il ne s'est pas
présenté qu'on ne sait pas où il est
mais j'ai toujours dit que que je verrai
mes impôts et et je paierai dès que ce
sera possible
abbott